PROFESSOR: Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So today, I'd like
to tackle a problem
in undetermined
coefficients, specifically
find a particular
solution to each
of the following equations
using undetermined coefficients.
So for part A, we have
x dot plus 3x equals
t squared plus t.
And for B, we have x dot
dot plus x dot equals t
to the four.
So I'll let you work
this problem out.
And I'll come back in a minute.
Hi Everyone.
Welcome back.
So we're asked to solve this
problem using the method
of undetermined coefficients.
And specifically, the
observation is if we have
a differential equation
with constant coefficients,
and we have a forcing on
the right-hand side which is
a polynomial, then there's
always going to be a particular
solution, which is a polynomial,
that has the form of some
constant times t to the power
of r plus constant t^(r-1) plus
a constant c_(r-2) t^(r-2)
plus dot, dot, dot,
plus c_1*t and then
possibly plus c_0.
And typically, the
problem is to find out
what's the highest-order
polynomial that we
should guess.
These constant c's,
they're referred to as
the undetermined coefficients.
And these are the constants
that we seek to solve.
So for our first
differential equation,
we have x dot plus 3x
equals t squared plus t.
And the power that we
should guess for a solution
are, it's always going to be
at least as high as the highest
power on the right-hand side.
So the right-hand side tells
us at least the largest
that we should at least
start our guess at.
And then, sometimes, we have
to knock it up a few orders
depending on what the
lowest-order derivative
on the left-hand side is.
So in this case, the term
on the left-hand side,
there's no derivative term.
And so what we can
do for this case
is we can just take
r is equal to 2,
the power of the polynomial
on the right-hand side.
So we're going to seek
a guess or an ansatz,
which is some constant
A times t squared
plus B times t plus
some constant C.
And again, I've taken
the highest polynomial
that we should guess to be 2,
because the right-hand side is
2 in this case.
So now what we do is
we just substitute this
in into the
differential equation.
And we choose our A, B, and C
to construct this as a solution.
So let's go ahead and do that.
So taking its derivative, we
have 2A*t plus B. And then,
we have 3 times A*t
squared plus B*t plus C.
And we want this to be
equal to t squared plus t.
And now, the only way
that the left-hand side
is going to equal
the right-hand side
is if the coefficients in
front of each polynomial
are the same.
So in the left-hand
side, we only
have one term that
has a t squared in it.
And that must, therefore,
equal the t squared term
on the right-hand side.
So these two terms have
to be equal to each other.
So we end up getting that
3A has to be equal 1.
And so A is equal to one third.
And now what we do is we
collect terms with a power of t.
This gives us 3B plus 2A
on the left-hand side,
so that's this
term and this term.
And we want that t equal t on
the right-hand side or just 1.
Now, we already know that
A is equal to one third.
So we end up getting that
3B is equal to 1 minus 2/3,
which is equal to one third.
Put 3B as one third, which
means that B is equal to 1/9.
And now lastly,
to determine C, we
see that B plus 3C must be 0.
So B plus 3C is 0, or C
is equal to negative 1/27.
So notice how we always
start with the highest power.
In this case, A
is the coefficient
in front of t squared.
That lets us solve
for A. And then
the rest of the
undetermined coefficients,
we can solve for, almost
like a giant zipper.
So the particular solution
that we just constructed,
when the dust settles is 1/3 t
squared plus 1/9 t minus 1/27.
So this concludes part A.
For part B, we have the
differential equation
x dot dot plus x dot
equals t to the four.
And in this case, we know
that the right-hand side
is a power of four.
So we should guess at least
a fourth-order polynomial.
However, we see that there's
no constant multiple of x.
In fact, the lowest-order
derivative is 1.
So what this means
is we should actually
knock the solution that we
guess up one order polynomial.
So we should try and guess x is
equal to A t to the fifth plus
B t to the four plus C t cubed
plus D t squared plus E*t.
And we can leave out an F term.
We can leave out a constant.
Because if we just substitute
that in the left-hand side,
we see that the x dot dot is
going to vanish, and x dot
is going to vanish.
So we can omit
any constant term.
So let's seek this
ansatz, and plug it
into the differential equation.
And if we do that,
we get 20A t cubed.
And this is plugging
into the x dot dot term.
This term is going to give us
12B t squared plus 6C*t plus D.
And then the x dot term is going
to give us 5A t to the four
plus 4B t cubed plus 3C t
squared plus 2D*t plus E.
And we want the sum of these two
terms to equal t to the four.
So again, what we do is we
start with the highest power.
We see that on the
left-hand side,
we have 5A must be
equated with just 1.
So we have 5A is equal to
1, or A is equal to 1/5.
Secondly, we're
going to have 20A
plus 4B equals the 0
polynomial, or the 0 which
is the coefficient of t cubed.
And this gives us B is
equal to negative 5A, which
is negative 1.
And now for the quadratic
terms, we have 12B plus 3C is 0.
So C is going to equal
negative 4B, which
is negative 4 times negative
1, which just gives us 4.
The linear term is going
to give us 6C plus 2D
equals 0, which gives us
D is equal to negative 3C,
which gives us negative 12.
And then the last
term is D plus E
is 0, which gives
us E is equal to 12.
So at the end of
the day, we end up
with a particular
solution, which
is a polynomial of 1/5 t to
the five minus 2 to the four
plus C, which is 4, t cubed
plus D, which is negative 12,
t squared plus E,
which is 12, times t.
And by construction,
this polynomial
solves the differential
equation with a forcing of t
to the four on the
right-hand side.
So just to recap,
when we're faced
with an undetermined coefficient
problem, what we have to do
is we just guess a solution,
which is a polynomial.
And the main difficulty is
just guessing the highest power
of the polynomial.
And that's always going to be at
least as big as the polynomial
on the right-hand side.
But as we saw in
part B, we sometimes
have to knock it up a
few orders depending
on what the differential
equation actually is.
So I'd like to conclude here.
And I'll see you next time.